ير الى الخبر العاجل الذي يظهر على شاشتنا
والذي يفيد بقصف مدفعي عنيف بمحيط مستشفى
الامل في خانيونس واطلاق نار كثيف من
مسيرات هذا الخبر اضافه الى ما توفر من
معلومات ايضا عن العمليات الاسرائيليه
والقصف في خانيونس ومناطق الجنوب تحديدا
معك
[موسيقى]
مؤمن
نعم حسن اخر التطورات بالفعل هو قصف مدفعي
اسرائيلي عنيف في محيط مستشفى الامل
التابع لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في
حي الامل حتى ان شضايا الصواريخ والقذائف
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه تطايرت على مبنى
المستشفى وايضا المبنى المجاور له التابع
للجمعيه والذي يؤوي الاف النازحين
الفلسطينيين الى جانب ان طائرات مسيره
اسرائيليه تطلق نيران
اسلحتها الرشاشه تجاه هذه المنطقه التي
تعج بالنازحين وايضا ب السكان من سكان
المنازل المجاوره ايضا تجددت الاشتباكات
المسلحه العنيفه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في عدد من
المناطق في وسط مدينه خانيونس وتحديدا في
محيط شارع القسام سمع دوي انفجارات قويه
نتيجه القصف المدفعيه من قبل الدبابات
الاسرائيليه الى جانب دوي اطلاقات ناريه
كثيفه من نتيجه الاشتباكات العنيفه التي
تدور في تلك المنطقه بين المقاومه وقوات
الاحتلال الى جانب محاور الاشتباك
المستمره في خزاعه ومعا وايضا منطقه بني
سهيله بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه كتائب
القسام اعلنت عن سلسله من الاستهدافات
للاليات وايضا للقوات الراجله الاسرائيليه
في هذه المناطق الثلاث بالاضافه الى
المحور الشمالي الغربي والشمالي الشرقي من
المدينه في بلده قراره الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه قصفت مجموعه من المواطنين قرب
منطقه اصداء غرب مدينه خانيونس اسفرت هذه
الغاره عن استشهاد فلسطينيين اثنين ليرتفع
عدد الشهداء منذ فجر اليوم وحتى هذه
اللحظه نتيجه الغارات والقصف الاسرائيلي
المتواصل على مدينه خان يونس الى اثان الى
22 شهيدا الى جانب مئات الجرح الذين يصلون
الى مستشفى ناصر في المدينه الى جانب
مستشفى غزه الاوروبي الواقع الى الجنوب
الشرقي من المدينه في وسط القطاع الامور
تزداد سوءا مع توغل الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في مخيم المغازي وايضا منطقه
الزوايده هناك العشرات من العائلات ما
زالت محاصره داخل منازلها ولا تستطيع
النزوح من تلك المناطق الى منطقه دير
البلح نتيجه الاستهداف المباشر من قبل
قناصه جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كما ان
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه شنت غاره
جويه قبل قليل في محيط منطقه ابراج عين
جالوت في مخيم النصيرات في المنطقه الوسطى
نتحدث عن 25 شهيدا منذ ساعات الفجر وحتى
هذه اللحظه الى جانب مئات الجرحى شكرا لك
مؤمن اشرافي من خان يونس مراسل الجزيره
ومن خانيونس